joining us now with your action is the
host of kudlow on the fox business
network larry kudlow's extensive
experience in
finances in the white house uh larry the
idea that we took our strategic
petroleum reserve
and much of that oil ended up in china
that is not what the president said he
was doing
yeah it's a very strange story i mean
that's about as much we don't have
enough details
but
some of these strategic petroleum
reserves
were exported to europe
and then through trading companies
made their way to india
and
perhaps china we don't know all that we
need to know
i don't really understand look there's a
couple things here jason let's kind of
break this down
first point is i don't know why we have
to export strategic petroleum reserves
what we should be doing is exporting lng
okay that's the key to help europe out
and reduce their dependency uh
particularly on russian gas but also
russian oil that's what we should be
doing but you know no leases and no
permits um has stopped all that so
that's point number one point number two
oil is fungible it doesn't really affect
the price
i you know whether it's here or overseas
uh it's a world market and i just want
to say
what's happened more important i mean
this is a dumb thing don't get me wrong
it's a very dumb thing and they've
gotten rid of or by the end of october
they will have gotten rid of almost 50
percent of our strategic petroleum
reserve which itself is a dumb thing
because that's about energy security and
national security okay but but but
what's going on is that
russia
is selling heavily to india
and to china
so
russian oil production
is about pre-war levels because of those
two customers now they're selling at a
discount um 25 30 perhaps but you're
still a hundred dollars a barrel or more
so russia's making a fortune uh india
and china are sustaining putin's war
machine by the same token because joe
biden has a very far left uh climate
change policy you know all this
craziness um there's no leases you saw
that from the interior department um
they're not granting permits uh either
for drilling or pipelining or refining
now this may change you know because of
the supreme court decision west virginia
versus the epa which is a terrific
decision and a lot of this stuff's going
to be held up in court but nonetheless
we're not getting the production of oil
or gasoline because the bidens are
violently against all that meanwhile
russia
with china and india have blown up
they've completely blown up the oil
sanctions
but larry what to me permeates this
white house and this administration is
one of incompetence it it reminds me of
jimmy carter i mean joe biden was
actually a senator when when
when uh when jimmy carter was the
president united states uh those two
guys have known each other they got to
learn from each other and and the
problem is the president stands up and
says putin putin putin
and i'm going to release a strategic
petroleum reserve to help stabilize the
price of gas and then i'm paying 120 530
dollars to fill up my f-150 and people
are sick of it because this president
doesn't know what he's doing and he
blames somebody else why do we need joe
biden if he can't get it done
well that's an important question i
think you're going to get an answer come
november when the cavalry comes and
takes the house and most likely takes
the senate it's probably going to be a
landslide um
i actually was a wall street a junior
wall street economist during jimmy
carter's period so i actually remember
uh some of those crazy mistakes i mean
look at everything biden does is
permeated by this you know leftist
climate change green new deal he really
believes that we can abolish fossil
fuels he said it many times and he
really believes that this uh high price
of oil will be ameliorated mitigated uh
with the use of renewables and i got a
bolton for them
fossil fuels 80 of our power right now
the renewables you know maybe four or
five percent it's not going to happen
but they're stubborn and narcissistic
and self-centered so he's you know
blamed trump he's blamed kovid he's
blamed putin he's blaming all prices
he's even blaming gas stations because
the intern who wrote the tweet uh didn't
have econ 101 according to the oil and
gas that's right i love that tweet i
think it's absolutely fabulous and i
don't i don't think joe biden
understands it i mean i i don't know
what he knows you saw his press
secretary she doesn't understand it i
don't know who understand it all i can
say is we are not going to end fossil
fuels i mean maybe we will in a hundred
years or 150 years but it won't be any
sooner than that
yeah larry it is clear transportation
secretary buddha judge doesn't have a
clue the energy secretary doesn't have a
clue the commerce secretary said she
doesn't have any answers they don't have
any answers larry kudlow thanks for
joining us tonight on cuddle
on hannity tonight i really do
appreciate it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else